And sometimes in identical words
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that which translates to
and some people
argue against Allah or argue
about Allah
without knowledge
without guidance
and without a clear book.
So here we have three things that Allah
mentions.
These are the three sources of knowledge
for the human being. Anything that is
going to be called knowledge
is going to come from one of these three
places.
He mentions knowledge
guidance
and a clear book.
So knowledge here, what is meant by
knowledge is logic.
We're speaking about knowledge in its
two forms, the deductive and inductive.
Deductive, 2 - 1 is how much?
Come on guys, 2 - 1 is how much? One. Is
there anybody who has a different
opinion?
No, because it's deductive. Inductive is
based on experimentation.
Fire is hot. We all know that, right?
Could there be a fire in the future that
we have never seen that might not be
hot? Maybe, but what we know is that our
experience tells us that every fire you
touch is going to be hot and it's going
to burn you. Right?
Then we have the second type of
knowledge. So we have knowledge of
experience, what we learn from around
us.
Number two
we have guidance. What is meant by
guidance here? The scholars of tafsir
tell us guidance meaning a messenger
from Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
And that is one of two types of
revelation. Number one is the messenger,
and number two is the book that the
messenger receives.
And those two are mentioned separately
because the messenger's understanding of
the book is also part of the revelation.
Right? And we've discussed this before.
These are the only three
things which are considered to be
valid arguments or valid sources of
knowledge upon which to found our
arguments.
Knowledge, guidance, and a book from
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Anything else
is merely what? Whims, desires,
dressed up as knowledge. Emphatic
opinions,
very vehement, staunch positions.
Just because a person says it with
enthusiasm doesn't make it true.
Imagine here
that we have a detective.
And this detective,
he's called to a crime scene.
And before he even gets to the crime
scene, he jumps in his car
and he says
on his way to the crime scene,
"I know
who committed this crime,
and I've already solved the crime."
And then they get to the crime scene.
Now, there's evidence at the crime
scene, right? There's clues.
If a person already has an opinion
formed before receiving the evidence for
that opinion, what's going to happen?
He's going to twist all of the clues to
match that narrative, all of them.
And any clues that cannot be twisted, he
will discard them and avoid them and
ignore them.
And this happens all the time. This is
called confirmation bias.
Confirmation bias is one of the most
dangerous threats that threaten the
Muslimin today.
Why is that?
Because we are learning very little from
our book
and learning quite a lot from our
environment.
And then we're going back to our book to
only reaffirm what we think we already
know.
So, for instance,
a person believes
that this is how children should be
raised.
And so, they have an opinion on what is
right and what is wrong. Based on what?
Based on popular opinion, based on
TikTok, based on Instagram, based on
what so-and-so said, based on my past
experience, based on my relationship
with my parents, based on how I feel
that day, based at whatever junction I'm
at in life, and then I go to read the
Quran. What am I only going to be
looking for when I read the Quran?
Only what confirms what I already
believe.
And everything else, no matter how
glaringly obvious, I'm going to what?
Either twist it
or avoid it.
This is the most dangerous thing. This
is a very simple rule, very simple
principle.
You never believe something until you
have the evidence, and that evidence
leads you to that belief, never the
other way around.
How many people today
of so-called Muslimin, they will hear a
narration
and already, just because the narration
shocks their system with something they
haven't, you know, that contradicts what
they know to be true, immediately they
what?
They they form an opinion against it and
decide this narration is not authentic.
No way could the Prophet Muhammad that I
know ever say something this.
And then they'll go and do what? They'll
go search for whatever upholds that
belief
and whatever
contradicts that belief, they will
discard it or twist it.
And this happened in a very major way
which introduced one of the gravest in
innovations ever introduced into Islam.
The first innovation was what?
The first innovation in the history of
Islam, who knows?
Al-Khawarij.
And what is the basis of the Khawarij
belief?
They took verses of the Quran speaking
about the Kuffar and applied them to the
Muslimin. That was the basis of their
innovation.
And they believed it
and they were righteous, they tried to
be righteous.
So much so that the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam tells us
that an average companion would pale in
contrast to these men in their salah and
fasting and recitation of the Quran and
so forth.
But they had the belief before they had
the evidence.
And if you hold a belief before you
receive the evidence, you will you will
twist the evidence to fit your
narrative.
The next innovation was the innovation
of Al Qadariyyah. They believed that
there was no
destiny. Why? Because
they thought about it in their logic.
They couldn't understand how decree and
Al Qadar worked. They came to
conclusions and then they twisted the
Quran to meet that
those conclusions.
The next came the Jahmiyyah.
The Jahmiyyah
originate from the belief systems of the
philosophers of Greece and Rome and
Persia.
They believed
that
Aristotle and Plato and Socrates and all
of these characters, that these guys,
they were logicians.
And they only arrived at their
conclusions by way of unbiased logic.
And they confused inductive with
deductive.
And so they learned from Aristotle who
Allah is.
And then they went to the Quran and
found what? It clashes very strongly.
So what did they do?
You got to put one in the other. You
can't They can't both coexist.
So they tried to make the Quran fit into
Aristotle's
philosophy based on the idea that
Aristotle is a pure logician and that
true logic could never contradict
the Quran revelation. And what happened
as a result? They went astray and
thousands of scholars of Ahlus Sunnah
were put to the sword, were tortured,
were punished, were put in prisons for
decades. Why? Because they presupposed
a
a a conclusion and then they looked for
the evidence. This is the This is a case
of the cart before ahead of the donkey.
It has to be the other way around.
It has to be
the evidence first and that evidence
then leads you naturally, organically to
the truth. Now, alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
we don't have that problem as Muslimin.
You know why?
Because we have scholars that already
explained to us all of these
conclusions.
We have scholars that explained
everything. We don't have to put on our
Nancy Drew caps and go searching to find
out the conclusions. These things are
already concluded. They will tell us
what the Quran means, what the Sunnah of
the Prophet means. All we have to do is
accept and comply.
But what fights against that?
Modern racism,
modern feminism,
modern
misandry, modern
democracy, all of these ideas as to
how things should work.
We learn them and then we go and twist
the Quran to
mean whatever we want it to say.
I remember during the height of the
first and second Gulf War. I'm old
enough to remember the rhetoric that was
being said back at that time and I know
a lot of younger folks today they can't
really understand just how brainwashed
the average American was. But before the
internet and in the baby years of the
internet, Americans really believed that
they were on a crusade to spread the
light of democracy through the earth.
They really believed that we were
murdering people by the hundreds of
thousands in foreign countries that they
we were actually there to give them the
gift of democracy and emancipate their
women. That's what they thought they
were there for.
They all thought that.
They thought that they murdered over a
million Iraqis for that reason.
Africans, forget about it.
They got absolutely stuffed into the
meat grinder by their own leaders.
And all for what? To spread democracy.
Now, it's changed now. Now it's Now it's
this new humanism thing. But before
democracy was communism. And before that
it was fascism. And before that it was
in the name of Christianity. And before
that it was Darwinian evolution and so
forth. There's always a new theme.
And
where are the terrorists? Are they
hiding over there? Before the
terrorists, it was the weapons of mass
destruction. We'll have to come and get
them, right?
But then we came up with the terrorists
and you have terrorists in your country,
we're going to send drones and literally
bomb bomb you to oblivion while you're
having dinner or having breakfast,
right? And we justified all this by
what?
By the idea of spreading democracy.
During that time,
you would find people, men and women,
Muslimin,
who would use verses of the Quran and
narrations of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam as evidence
that communism is correct.
That democracy is correct. That fascism
is correct. That socialism is correct.
That feminism is correct now.
Now.
There are
modern,   Muslimi,
Muslim women
who believe that no man can speak on
behalf of a woman, and you have to be a
woman to know
what a woman is going through. You can't
say anything if you're not a woman. Are
you a woman? If you're not a woman, you
can't say anything about women.
Well, that presents a big problem
because your prophet is a man.
And the majority of his companions were
men, and the majority of scholars of
Islam are men.
And this gives us a kind of hermeneutics
of suspicion
across the board. Any man that speaks,
we're already
we are already suspicious of him. He's
speaking from
in lieu of his toxic masculinity,
right?
Or
if it's an Arab, how can you speak on
the plight of the black man in today's
world? You don't know what it's like.
The microaggressions is eating us alive.
We can't survive.
Right? This is exactly
what every fitna brings with it. And
what does a fitna truly bring with it? A
shubuha, it brings the conclusion before
the evidence.
And so we distrust our scholars. The
scholars leading their people astray,
that is not our history. That's the
history of Christianity and Judaism.
That's not our history.
Our history, the Muslims have never
disobeyed their scholars except that it
ended in tragedy.
And they never obeyed their scholars
except that they were given greatness on
[Arabic recitation]